[Applause]
so after he loses
uh-huh we got the cure oh
god [ __ ] you know what that shit's
about
what'd you think i don't think they
trusted trump to administer it bro
i mean that sincerely what do you mean
that they announced it now
i think that they announced it this way
because it's probably gonna take five
legs to tell the people pfizer announced
that
uh they have a vaccine and it's 90
effective right and stocks are
skyrocketing as we speak yeah everything
is up bro except amazon apparently well
uh yeah the stocks that were killed by
corona
are up and the stocks that did great
during corona are down
so like amazon thrives in corona and if
corona is over
it's going to come down a little bit to
a realistic number amazon's obviously
going to always be around but
airplane stocks went crazy because
[ __ ] are going to start
traveling again because they're not
terrified of the airport
but i think what this is is because it's
probably going to take them what like
six months or something like that to get
enough of these yeah the big issue with
is the cool chain
that's what they call it they call it
like the cool chain system so basically
like being able to transport
vaccines at scale at like super low
temperatures because they have to stay
like it like
right and you have to do that to 300 and
well they're saying 330 million people
probably 200 million people have to
take it right now specialized trucks
specialized airplanes all this [ __ ] to
keep it at like negative 100 degrees or
whatever and i think the argument with
kids is they might not need it but if
they can give it to people yeah
you might want your kid to have it right
but one whatever it doesn't matter the
point is
um if it's gonna take six or nine months
to get this [ __ ] to everybody
maybe what they did is they held on as
long as they possibly could
because they were like we don't believe
trump has the ability or the wherewithal
to execute the admit the administration
of this drug to wait six months
yeah not even wait six months but like
we don't know if he'll be able to do it
so maybe they had it three months ago
and maybe this is what trump kept on
talking about that's any day now it's
any day now and they were like uh
you need a few more minutes yeah because
they're like we think you'll botch this
you've botched corona we think you'll
watch this that's
what i was talking to some of my like
political folks they're like this has
probably been ready for a while
right and there's no i mean if this is
not a coincidence that they
they mention it the day after they
confirm the bias right because trump
might not be involved in the literal
like passing out and like transportation
of the drug but he could put out a tweet
like
i'm not getting no vaccine or whatever
not only not
he put he could probably put that out
right now and still [ __ ] it up maybe but
like
not only that but like he might try to
rush it he might go well who needs all
the [ __ ] cooling systems let's go out
there he might be
so anxious to get this drug to the
people that
he would risk the efficacy i believe the
term is of the drug
and that's why maybe there's some
pushback so
like i don't know i mean but also you
look at that you're like yo that's kind
of foul
that you're blaming politicians
that's foul if you had this [ __ ] six
months ago somebody's mom is dead
because you didn't put it out no no no
i don't think that's the case because uh
trials
take a really long time so it's like i
just think
they're at the 90 percent effective rate
because of the latest results of the
trials going on that's what they're
seeing
and they were just really happy to
report that i still don't think it's
ready for a distribution
a monday a monday news break though two
days
after the election seems so blatant
maybe it's it's so blatant it can't be
on purpose but like trump is gone
saturday the next moment you can drop
news basically
hey 90 uh efficacy on this vaccine let's
go
also during the debate they were like yo
trump you have a vaccine he was like
yeah it's coming like apparently
really good results and everyone called
him a liar biden called him a liar in
the debate he's like nah he's lying
he's not lying turns out yeah but what
happens when you lie so much
yeah that's the boy who cry wolf or the
girl whoever it was
it was a girl or a boy it was a boy it
was boy yeah why are you scared of that
wolf you all just run son
yeah what inside go inside don't you got
it inside
you're not gonna outrun a wolf [ __ ] us
come on bro
and wolves don't play yeah you can only
outrun bears and lions
yeah i'll run a bear obviously lions i'm
thinking differently now
oh now yeah because i've seen the the
side to side
but bears pigeon toed i'll run out i'll
outrun anything pigeon toed also there's
been a lot of uh
controversy over taylor's claim that she
ran oh yeah we're gonna
wait she's back when she's back when
she's back we're gonna have a whole
one i brought that up on idiots i
brought that up on idiots right yeah she
says she running 11-6 right someone in
the fragrance believed it because i
don't know what that means
yo someone in the flagrant reddit did a
whole breakdown of
mile per hour mile per hour with a bear
compared like analysis
compared to dk metcalf dk metcalf is
this wide receiver for the seattle
seahawks maybe the fastest man in the
league
one yeah one of the fastest guys in the
league and i think when he ran down
budaper he was running at like 22 miles
per hour and taylor's pace is like 24
miles
some
to prove a point because i won't be
trailing her by that much you're gonna
be second
control group control group bro youtube
tophav you couldn't even outrun a
[ __ ]
uh swiss prisoner or whatever the [ __ ]
police officers
did we make fun of the fact that kim
voted for
i did on social but yeah you know the
thing is for me is like what a [ __ ]
like
yo style bender comment to this [ __ ]
crack me up he said uh
that's a that's a clout trout you know
cloud trout
wow trout that is that's right trout is
hilarious
but that's what these these people will
do man so many layers of that that's so
good
the lips not only the both lips
could be like a trout yeah
so the thing is like when you were whole
when your whole like life is based
around clout or like likes or social
media attention
you don't even realize your own
hypocrisy so there's this picture that
she posts of
biden and kamala and she puts four blue
hearts
blue hearts mind you not red hearts like
you know her as been voting
right she gets behind biden this is the
levels of hypocrisy behind this are
unbelievable
she gets behind biden kamala what is the
one thing that she worked with trump on
freeing uh alex johnson i think prison
reform yeah
i want to work on prison reform right oh
that's a good point
kamala locking [ __ ] up
left and right in california for nothing
mind you
blocking evidence that could potentially
freedom right
biden the crime build dawn
getting people locked up leaving right
matter of fact the people that kim is
freeing
are probably on some level locked up
because of buying crime bills
how the [ __ ] are you going to put these
blue heart now i understand if you try
and do something like unity [ __ ]
but then you don't heart it you go i
understand we might have our
disagreements but i'm looking forward to
working with you on
on crime reform something like that
don't just throw these [ __ ] hearts
not to mention your husband ran
yeah your husband ran for president
yeah how the [ __ ] could you possibly put
that up
your husband ran and if you knew your
husband ran
as some massive um
ploy for attention if this was just a
big pr move and you knew the whole
[ __ ] time
[ __ ] you yeah don't act like you're some
activist
out here trying to make change and
you're gonna let your husband
potentially peel away votes
from one candidate
so that so that could either help or
affect
uh negatively a result that you wanted
do you know what i'm saying yeah
like this this woman bro so easy to hate
man
so easy like how do you make yourself so
easy to hate and don't get me wrong i
understand girls want to dress like them
and all that kind of [ __ ] and they're
like
fashion change the world fashionistas
and low-key like part of like
kanye's brand being so valuable look i'm
starting to think is like is it just
because these kardashian girls have so
much
goddamn clout when it comes to clothing
and they all put that [ __ ] on they made
it look hot
like i really am starting to wonder like
is kanye the reason why his [ __ ] is so
successful or does he happen to be
married to
the biggest influencers on the planet
especially in the clothing department
and they single-handedly built that [ __ ]
for kanye
one thing i'll give kanye is that he
kind of elevated kim's
fashion game when they got together but
their influence on fashion was still
pretty bad
years like they were in like in high
fashion like he he was his sneakers were
killing it before
kim the easiest i think were pretty big
before cameron they literally owned a
store that
sold clothes called dash that was what
they did for living no i know but i mean
like she wasn't respected in the high
fashion world she was still looked at as
just like a video vixen or whatever the
case is and then he got her on like
the vanity fairs and those bigger type
of magazines
fair enough maybe but i think the
regular average female was looking at
what she was wearing and going i want to
wear that
and now literally all them if any of
them wear a bag that bag is sold out if
any of them wear a pair of pants
those pants are sold out they wear
sandals those things are sold out
anything that they put on
is gold it's like when a first lady
wears some [ __ ] maybe not melania but
remember when michelle put on a dress
yeah and that [ __ ] was off the shelves
so i'm starting to think like all right
so maybe you guys are really at least
partially responsible for using oh for
sure
definitely they got it right i don't
know it's just such fraudulence i see
that
[ __ ] you should watch her with dave
letterman oh yeah yeah
oh you did yeah it's like i think she's
been doing this whole
social media clout thing for so long
she's convinced like she it's not a lie
anymore it's not [ __ ]
she's she andrew dice played it she like
started to believe
this character that she's put up like
she actually sounds genuine
about the law and getting people out
like she
really is about that she mentioned
armenia at all
no interesting huh
you